Il est quelle heure là?
22h50
Et là il est quelle heure là?
00h45
Quoi? Mais j’ai eu le temps de faire une partie.
Bon, je mets quoi, 8h?
Ca dépend, il est à quelle heure ton rendez-vousdemain ?
9h.
9h? Il y a une demie heure de route,
ça te laisse une demie heure pour déjeuner, t’habiller, te laver.
En admettant que tu te lèves direct?
Oh c’est bon, je me lève direct.
Genre tu vas te lever direct, tu vas pas attendre que…
Non non non. C’est moi qui décide. Je mets 8h.
Pas moins 10?
Non.  -Ok.
Eh!
Tu dors?
Allez, vérifie-moi.
Tu sais que t’as envie de me regarder.
En plus, il est 1h du mat.
Ou 2h. Ou 4h.
Ou peut-être 3h44.
Allez, si ça se trouve il te reste plein de temps à dormir.
Et non! Il te reste qu’une heure.
Et là tu vas pas arrêter d’y penser mon pote.
Réveille-toi!
Réveille-toi !
On avait dit 5 minutes de plus.
Non non, on avait dit 8h je m’en rap…
Réveille-toi!
Tu m'entends encore ?
Réveille-toi,
Merde !
Ah ben ouais mais je t’avais prévenu hein.
Elle arrive à 20h, il est quelle heure là?
19h30.
Et maintenant il est quelle heure là?
19h32.
Quoi? Mais t’es bloqué ou quoi?
T’es relou à me suspecter!
Tu dis ça parce que je suis un réveil, c’est ça?
Non.
C’est chaud, elle m’a regardé.
Oui,
encore deux minutes et tu bas ton record.
Ouais, non,
par contre me regardes pas parce que
là j’ai l’impression que c’est moi qui t’excite et c’est chelou.
Ouais, gênant.
C’est qui ça?
Non mais t’y arriveras jamais comme ça.